bachelor in paradise is Amanda Stanton
and Robbie Hayes weigh in on those
cheating accusations we tried to date
outside the show and whatever but you
know I'm friendly with them we caught up
with the reality stars at the bachelor
end of summer party benefiting restore
dignity on Wednesday and they opened up
about what went wrong after paradise
wrapped they promo has come out for the
finale and in that promo
the twins accused you of cheating on
Amanda you did cheat on Amanda
there was pictures coming out is that
true that's all what happened in
Colorado then did you cheat on Amanda no
comments at this time
when will there be a comment soon is
there a lot that you want to say a lot
that I'd like to say did Robbie cheat on
you
so basically what happened was there is
a night and Ricky was out in Colorado in
Denver and he was supposed to come home
that night but he had missed his flight
and his phone died and I didn't hear
from him for like a whole day and then
the next day you know he had called me
in the morning and he's like sorry my
phone died and later that day a girl
said that he was at his background and
concert and sent me photos of him
looking like and they were making out
all over each other he said that they
were not so I wasn't there so I don't
know and I yeah so do you have an
inclination one way or the other I mean
at this point it doesn't really matter
you know what I mean but the photos look
like they're their mouths
[Music]
you